- Airships seem like a bad idea.
Exhibit A.
(bright upbeat music)
- It's the greatest of
miracles that anyone
came out of the disaster alive.
- The Hindenberg was filled
with over 200 million liters of hydrogen
but it also had an iron oxide
and aluminum powder coating
on its outer shell,
two of the ingredients that make thermite,
a mixture that undergoes
such a strongly exothermic reaction,
it is used to weld train tracks together.
But even if airships weren't
giant sacks of flammable gas
encased in questionable coatings,
they would still seem like a bad idea
because they are big and slow.
But right now, a handful of
companies around the world
are competing to build a
new generation of airships.
So why are they doing it?
I came across the following argument
in a blog by Eli Dourado
and I found it compelling
so I wanted to explore it.
Think about how goods, all
the different types of stuff,
are transported around the U.S..
A large amount of money is spent
moving things around by airplane
but this doesn't translate
into a huge volume of goods
because air transport is really expensive.
It's the fastest way
to get something from one place to another
but you pay a premium for that speed.
If you want to save money,
you can transport your goods
on ships using the waterways
in and around the country
but that will be much slower.
Still, since it's significantly cheaper,
far more goods are transported this way
and more money is spent on it overall.
Rail provides an even better option.
It's faster than ships
and cheaper than planes,
so more goods are sent by train
than by air and water combined.
But by far the way that most
goods are moved around the U.S.
is by truck.
What's interesting about
this is that trucks
are not as fast as planes,
they take several days to
get across the country.
They are also not as cheap as ships
but the combination of speed and price
puts them in this sweet spot
of cheap enough and fast enough
which is why they transport
the vast majority of goods.
They are like the baby bears
porridge of transport options,
just right.
Now consider how goods are
transported internationally.
The only options are planes and ships.
Again, a lot of money is
spent sending goods by air
but because it's so expensive,
the actual volume of goods is low.
And most goods, both in
terms of dollars and weight
are sent via ocean freight.
But what if there were a third option;
faster than ships and cheaper than planes?
It seems likely that most
customers would prefer this new
truck-like method of transport.
Airships could be this option.
(bright upbeat music)
They could be the trucks of the sky.
They would transport cargo
across oceans in around a week
rather than a month for freighters.
And theoretically, they would
be several times cheaper
than sending goods by plane.
And they would achieve all this
while emitting significantly
less emissions than planes.
See, while planes get
their lift from their wings
and so they need to burn a lot of jet fuel
just to stay in the air,
airships get their lift
effectively for free.
The buoyancy of lighter-than-air
gas keeps them up
so they don't need to move
forward to stay aloft.
As a result, modern airship
manufacturers estimate airships
can reduce carbon
emissions by 90% or more.
But for airships to become
the trucks of the sky,
they would have to carry a lot of weight
and historically, that has
not been a particular strength
of airships but that's
where the physics comes in.
The lift of an airship depends
on the volume of light of
an air gas it contains,
so lift is proportional to radius cubed.
Whereas drag depends on a
combination of the cross-sectional
and wedded area,
that is basically the
surface area of the craft.
So it's proportional to radius squared.
This means the bigger you make an airship,
the more efficient it becomes.
Lift goes up proportional to radius cubed
whereas drag only goes up
proportional to radius squared.
So there's a cubed squared
advantage for larger airships.
Want to boost the
performance of your airship?
We'll just double it in size.
The area grows by a factor of four
the volume by a factor of eight.
So your lift to drag ratio doubles.
If that's not enough,
just double it again.
To make airships the trucks of the sky,
we'd need to build
the largest airships
the world has ever seen.
There are three different
kinds of airships.
The first is a blimp,
which is basically a
balloon with a gondola
and motors attached.
Like a balloon,
it is over-pressurized
to maintain its shape.
Therefore, the skin of a
blimp is in constant tension.
As the blimp becomes larger,
this tension increases.
Moreover, it becomes
increasingly difficult
for larger blimps to maintain their shape.
So you can't scale up blimps forever.
The second option is semi-rigid.
Just like a blimp, the
hull is still in tension
yet now there's some
added structural support
to maintain the shape.
The last variety is a rigid body airship.
These have an internal structure
to maintain their shape.
Inside the hull, there
are a series of gas cells
filled with a lifting gas
like hydrogen or helium.
In this case, the gas cells
are not over pressurized
so making them larger is no issue.
The great thing about rigid airships
is that they don't run into
the same scaling limits.
Want a bigger airship?
Just scale up the structure
and add some extra gas bags.
In fact, the weight of the
structure actually decreases
as a fraction of the total weight,
so rigid airships scale even
better than square cubed.
So it's this last option
that is best suited for the cargo market.
And that's what Eli proposes:
to build a 388 meter long rigid airship
to conquer the cargo market
it would be capable of
carrying 500 tons of goods
at a speed of 90 kilometers per hour.
That's enough to carry
two Statues of Liberty
at the speed you drive down the highway.
If built, it would be the
largest aircraft by far
both in size and in how
much weight it could carry.
Not bad for an airship.
But to take a significant
piece of the cargo market,
you don't need just one airship,
you need a fleet of thousands
constantly moving goods around the globe.
And if they take over half
of the ocean freight container market
at a price comparable to trucks,
say 10 cents per ton kilometer,
that would equal $650
billion of revenue per year.
And if that was all served by one company,
it would be the biggest company
in the world by revenue.
Bigger than Apple or Amazon or Walmart.
So who is building these monster airships?
Well, at the moment, no one.
This part of the video
is sponsored by odoo.com.
Just like airships, many
of our own dream projects
can be hard to get off the ground
but the first step is always the same,
you just have to get started.
And whether you want to
start a business, a blog,
or a side hustle,
one easy way to get started
is to launch your own website.
This signals to the world
and yourself that you
are really doing this.
And if you want a fast, free and easy way
to launch your own website,
then check out this
video sponsor, odoo.com.
Just answer a few simple questions,
select your favorite theme and
then Odoo's powerful software
builds the core website for you.
Then you simply go to
any block and change it.
Want to add an image?
Just select the image block
and drag it to where you want it.
Next, click Replace to swap
it with one of your own images
or if you don't have an image,
just pick one of their free to use images.
Adding a new page is also really easy.
Just click New and add a
page and then drag and drop
the blocks you want and you're done.
With Odoo, making your own
website is a piece of cake.
On top of that, Odoo also offers
everything from accounting
to email marketing apps which
can be easily integrated
with your website.
With Odoo, your first
application is free for life,
including unlimited hosting and support
and a free custom domain
name for one year.
So head over to odoo.com/r/veritasium
or click that link down in the description
to start building your own website today.
I want to thank Odoo for
sponsoring today's show.
While transporting cargo
is probably the largest
market for airships,
it's also one that's driven
by fierce competition
and low margins.
And that's not ideal when you
need to spend a lot of money
to first build, develop,
and certify your airship.
What you want is a market
with less competition
and better margins.
This is the Airlander 10,
and it's built by the U.K.
company Hybrid Air Vehicles.
Can you tell me about the
envisioned use of the Airlander?
- They'll be going on extraordinary
experiential holidays.
So going to the North
Pole, going on a safari,
going over the Amazon,
knowing that they're making
almost no environmental impact,
being able to travel in some luxury
and see things that you
just can't do another way.
- The first trips are scheduled
for no later than 2026.
Want to go on this trip, well,
you'd better start saving
because getting a cabin for two
will cost you about $200,000.
And while a few companies are focusing
on the luxury travel markets,
others plan to make use
of another unique advantage of airships.
Think about what it normally
takes to move things around.
Trucks need roads, ships
need water and ports,
trains need railways and stations
and planes need long runways and airports.
Airships on the other hand,
require very little infrastructure.
The most important thing they need
is a reasonably flat surface to land on,
like grass, sand, ice or even water.
And it's this unique
ability that allows them
to deliver goods where
no truck, boat, train,
or plane can go.
Airships can connect parts of the world
that have been disconnected
forever such as remote villages
in Canada or Alaska
and they can do this with
little to no infrastructure.
Or what if the roads, rails
and ports have been destroyed
by a natural disaster?
Help is urgently needed to
find and support the survivors
but there seems to be no way to get there
and no methods of communications
once you are there.
Well, then airships could
quickly rush to the scene
to deliver rescue workers and supplies
or to provide cellular
service from the sky.
Disaster relief missions like
these are what LTA Research,
which is backed by Google
co-founder Sergey Brin,
is focusing on and they're
making great progress.
Their current prototype, the Pathfinder 1,
has completed multiple indoor flight tests
and it's scheduled to fly outside
sometime in the next few months.
They plan to take the lessons
they learn from these tests
and build a series of airships
that can provide help to
disaster stricken areas.
Other times, roads may be available
but what you're transporting
just isn't that compatible with roads
like long, clunky and
fragile turbine blades.
To get them from the
factory to the destination
requires careful planning
and perfectly choreographed maneuvers
and this process is what often limits
the size of wind turbines.
Airships don't have that problem,
they can simply mount
turbine blades of any size
to the bottom and carry
them to the destination.
So it's much faster, easier
and it allows you to build
more powerful wind turbines.
Plus airships can also easily
transport other structures
that are hard to move.
But sometimes instead of delivering goods,
you need to pick them up.
France is full of natural
resources like wood,
yet many of their forests
can't be reached by truck
so they can't actually extract the wood
they've chopped down.
The French company Flying whales,
backed by the French government
is hoping to change that.
They are developing this
200 meter long cargo ship
that's capable of
carrying a 60-ton payload.
It was designed to be able
to hover above remote forests
and pick up logs which
could then be carried off
and turned into timber.
But loading and unloading from the sky
comes with significant problems.
For starters, you need to make
sure that during this process
your airship stays still
which is more difficult than it sounds.
- So a very large airship
has what we call sail effect.
Even a relatively light current of wind
when multiplied by a
really, really large area
is going to have a huge effect,
that makes airships difficult to control
especially close to the
ground and at low speeds.
So they are a little bit unwieldy.
- To overcome this, the airship
is fitted with propellers
all around the hull that can stabilize it.
But still this limits
the use of most airships
to places with stable weather.
A bigger problem comes
from the fundamental reason
why airships work in the first place.
And this issue is particularly
bad for large cargo airships.
See, when an airship is
carrying a heavy load,
the combined weight of
the load and the airship
are offset by the lift.
The problem arises when
you release that heavy load
because now the airship
is suddenly much lighter
and so it wants to shoot up into the sky.
So you need some way to
stop that from happening.
- Unless we can solve that problem,
we're kind of dead in the water
in terms of airships for cargo.
- A few methods have been
proposed to solve this problem.
The easiest one is to decrease
lift by venting lifting gas.
The only issue is that most
modern airships use helium.
And to offset say 60 tons of weight,
you would need to release
about 54,000 cubic meters of helium
which costs a few
hundred thousand dollars.
Not to mention that helium is scarce,
so venting it isn't
really a practical option.
Now, you could use propellers
to push the airship down
but that ends up burning so much fuel,
it negates much of the advantage
of using airships in the first place.
- The real dream has been to compress
and decompress lifting gas
because you take a lifting gas
and when it is in gaseous form, it lifts.
When it is compressed,
it's ballast, it's heavy,
but there are some real
problems with that.
So you're talking about
a very large airship
with a very large volume of lifting gas,
now you need a compressor that's capable
of compressing a tremendous
amount of gas very quickly
and that is just a technological problem
we haven't really developed them.
- Until then, the short-term solution
is to replace the weight you're releasing.
So if you're dropping 60 tons of supplies,
you need to pick up 60 tons of ballast.
If you want to pick up 60 tons of wood,
you'd carry 60 tons of say water on board
and release it at the pickup location.
But there's another innovative
way to solve this problem
and it's the secret behind
how the Airlander 10 works.
It relies on a combination
of lift from helium
and aerodynamic lift created by its hull.
- We can lift the whole
weight of the aircraft
with the helium inside
so that effectively,
when you're flying, that weighs nothing.
- And the aerodynamic lift
is just there to lift the payload.
- So if we've, say, got
100 people on board,
we take off like a conventional aircraft,
just at very low speed and we
generate the aerodynamic lift
to lift those people.
The advantage then is that
when we come down on the ground
and those people get
off, we don't float away
'cause we used aerodynamic lift
which you can turn on and off.
- While hybrid airships work well
for relatively light payloads,
they're not ideal for
carrying heavy payloads
over long distances because
you would lose the advantage
of using free lift to
carry all that weight.
So for a large cargo airships,
the current best solution
to the load exchange problem
is to replace the weight you're releasing.
But there are harder problems
that you need to overcome
to make airships the trucks of the sky.
See, no one has ever built a
388 meter long airship before.
So how do you do it?
Well, normally airships are
built in humongous hangers
to protect them from the elements.
But the largest airship
hanger that's ever been built
was only 360 meters long.
So it wouldn't even fit.
And since you need to build
thousands of these airships
you either have to find a way
to magically construct scores
of fragile airships outside
or build lots and lots
of the world's largest hangers.
If that wasn't hard enough,
there's also another problem
that needs to be solved
because each one of those
airships must be filled
with over one million cubic
meters of lifting gas.
Which raises the age old question,
do you use hydrogen or helium?
- Helium's really expensive
and it has a lower lifting ability, right?
Hydrogen's really cheap
but it'll kill you.
- After the Hindenburg burned
down in less than 40 seconds,
the choice seemed obvious.
Only inert helium should
be used for airships.
The Federal Aviation Administration agreed
and hydrogen as a lifting gas
has been banned for many years now.
But what many people don't realize
is that of the 97 people on board,
more than 60 miraculously survived.
Just a few years earlier,
another airship, the USS Akron,
crashed off the coast of New Jersey
killing 73 of the 76 people on board.
And that airship was filled with helium.
So perhaps the issue
wasn't that hydrogen airships
were inherently unsafe,
maybe we just didn't know
how to build safe airships.
I mean, we also didn't know
how to build safe planes
and now they're one of
the safest ways to travel.
And for any plan that includes building
and filling thousands
of large scale airships,
hydrogen is the only realistic option
because helium is too
scarce and expensive.
Hydrogen, on the other hand,
is easy to produce, cheap
and it provides about 8% more lift.
And then there's the
issue of certification.
- In general, certificating
any new aircraft
is a really lengthy and expensive process.
If you're talking about
certificating an airship,
not only are you talking
about a brand new aircraft,
you're talking about a
brand new type of aircraft.
No one has certificated
a large rigid airship in
well, sort of ever.
- Combine that with building
the largest aircraft
the world has ever seen and filling it
with tremendous amounts
of a highly flammable gas
and you've got yourself
another pretty big challenge.
But all of these problems
may not even matter
because it might not be possible
to build a 500 ton
cargo ship of that size.
- I mean, the most important
thing of an airship structure
is needs to be light,
it needs to be robust,
it needs to be strong,
it needs to have really
good structural integrity
but it needs to be light
enough to get off the ground
or there's no point.
And at a certain point of size,
the weight you need to add
to create the structural integrity
you need to operate safely,
you know, you reach a
point where those curves
just intersect in a bad way.
So there is a structural size limitation
due to weight issues.
- So how large is that size?
We are not sure.
What we do know is that
right now several companies
around the world are
developing and building
the next generation of airships.
For now, none of them are
setting out to develop
the trucks of the sky.
Instead, they're focusing
on areas where airships
have a distinct advantage;
markets with less competition
and decent margins.
Who knows, perhaps as airships mature,
one company will take the leap
and set out to develop
these trucks of the sky.
It certainly won't be easy,
but the reward could be huge.
Do you think we'll see a future where
we've got these airships
roaming all over our skies?
- I know it may sound
crazy but we really do.
- It won't be very, very long
before we get to see some stuff in the sky
which will make a lot
of people, including me,
have really big smiles and
a lot of happy nostalgia
for the great airships of the past.
- It's very hard to break into
the world with a new thing
that the world's not ready for.
I mean, there are many other things
that have become normal
after a bit of time.
And there's no reason why this shouldn't.
- I hope when that day
comes someone will invite me
to come along and at least take a look,
if not have a ride in it.
(soft upbeat music)